make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with
avengers and new avengers and in this
one
we're picking up with the black priests
now the black priests were
a wildly confusing concept among the
comic book fan base when they were
initially introduced because
it was it was kind of hard to wrap our
heads around the idea of how they
functioned what they did like how they
worked that kind of thing
this will clear all that up right like
this this will clear all that up and
make it all make sense
right so what we end up doing here is
picking up with this space it's
basically the nothing space of destroyed
universes
all this is is basically the space that
universes occupied before they were
wiped out right now one of the cool
things to point out here is the way that
jonathan hickman's able to pull this off
is because of the old captain britain
comics with mad jim jasper's that's why
he's able to pull this off because that
was really the first time in marvel
comics that we got a depiction of what a
universal space looks like when its
universe is destroyed
right you had mad jim jaspers from earth
238 who had wiped out all the
superheroes the the omniversal
development court didn't know that and
so they basically
initiated the push which is to say
pushing the evolution of the of the
various denizens on that earth and
basically jump starting the creation of
mutants this led to mad jim jasper's
getting pissed off and initiating the
jasper's warped which threatened
the entirety of the multiverse and so in
order to keep that from happening the
omniversal development court obliterated
his entire universe right just wiped the
whole thing out and it was just a giant
white void that's what's left whenever a
universe is destroyed just a giant white
space right it's like a white piece of
paper with nothing drawn on it
and that's what the multiversal avengers
have been finding they've been going
from from universe to universe and
either finding a giant white space
or encountering like uh the sadera
madris right so like the map makers they
encountered a black priest on a world
and they destroyed that black priest
but like that was just a lone black
priest out there somewhere what they've
done here
it's probably the worst possible thing
they could have which is to land
in the main base of operations of the
black priest now one thing to know
they don't know where they're going
right that's the reason why robert de
costa told
thor this is a one-way trip they don't
know what universe they're going to end
up in right they can't plan
and direct where it is they're going to
arrive at they literally just open a
portal jump to the next universe and
then whatever's there is there right so
they could end up in an entire universe
that's filled with
like like the mad celestials for example
from jonathan hickman's fantastic four
and then just be completely and totally
subdued there's a possibility for them
to escape if things get bad enough but
the issue is that this portal is rapidly
closing because as soon as they arrive
the black priests are prepared for them
right the black priests were basically
awaiting you know waiting for them to
show up and immediately start closing
the portal off right so there's no real
way for them to escape
and so because of that a massive battle
immediately starts breaking out and this
is when the black priests start to use
their words right they start to use the
phrases they use
in order to wipe things out now this is
what confused people
right this is what threw people off is
how the black priests function right
because
the the magic of a particular word so uh
to make this clear and make this easy to
understand
let's say that what we wanted to do was
we wanted to turn a table into a chair
right we wanted to re-materialize the
table we wanted to alter its atomic
structure
so that we could turn it into a chair
and let's say that we had to have a
spell to do it right let's say the spell
was
table into chair right three words the
way that you and i work
is we can just say table into chair and
then the table becomes the chair with
black priests it doesn't work that way
one priest can say table one priest can
say into
and one priest can say chair and in
order to turn the table into a chair
they have to speak those words in
sequence they come together right so
if you kill any one of those priests
they cannot turn the table into a chair
because the word they need
to to basically you know perform that
spell is gone now right it doesn't exist
right so that's that's the way the black
priests work but that's also what makes
them so incredibly powerful because
they're capable of wild feats but
they're but if you guys notice because
of that because of that that huge caveat
they're almost kind of broken right like
you would think that like if they really
are that powerful they would be able to
use all those words right like you
wouldn't need
a whole bunch of priests in order to do
something any one of them could do it
but as a collective
entity as a collective whole they are
insanely powerful but there is a reason
why they function that way and this
reason will be explained here in a
minute but the cool thing is that in the
middle of all this
uh basically like with a black priest
destroying ex-nahili everywhere
almost all over the place the battle is
boating ill for the various
for for the multiversal avengers they
quite literally showed up in the lion's
den and they're falling just
rapidly right person after person after
person is falling you know when it when
really it just kind of ends up dwindling
down to the core group right abyss
ex in the hilo uh thor hyperion but then
we also end up finding out that thor has
mjolnir now this is not the mjolnir from
the main marvel universe right remember
this took place after the events of
original sin odin's son is not worthy of
wielding his own hammer anymore that
belonged to jane foster but the reason
why thor has this hammer is that if you
guys recall
we had a previous video that we did
where we had an alternate reality
avengers team that were evil and that
the hammer said that the hammer was made
for that evil version of thor right
you know whosoever holds this hammer if
they be unworthy shall possess the power
of thor's
spelled with two r's and once that
avengers team was defeated they ended up
of course traveling back to their own
universe but the hammer stayed behind if
you guys recall that
that's where thor gets this hammer this
is one of those moments where jonathan
hickman does something
15 issues ago and it doesn't become
important until right now it's one of
the reasons why hickman's
so cool when it comes to writing stories
because you kind of have it's easier to
follow if you just
read it in its entirety all at one time
as opposed to like waiting for piece by
piece to come out because i can kind of
create issues right that's why i always
felt hickman is a great trade paperback
writer right he writes for the trade and
it's cool
it's awesome to to see how this is done
but thor of course recalls his hammer
and is like
relishing in the experience right like
it's so good to finally have this hammer
back
and it's so good to finally rip these
guys up right to tear these guys apart
you know and and to to use it the way
that i always used to
and it's kind of interesting because
despite what the black priests try to do
in terms of quelling the hammer they
can't
right they can't quite quell the hammer
but the the multiversal avengers also
start picking up on the idea
that if they start killing members of
the black priest they won't be able to
complete certain spells
and so that's what happens they
literally start destroying as many
priests as they can find to prevent them
from being able to use the spells now
the other thing is
there's only a finite number of priests
and so when a priest is destroyed that
word is gone forever
right so imagine that you could never
ever ever speak
the word happy right like imagine you
could never speak that word again how
would you convey that emotion
how would you convey the fact that you
you are happy there are other words that
are close to it but none of them
quite really you know convey how it is
that you're feeling
like the word happy and so with that
word gone for them it's doubly so
because
now they're spells that they can't use
there's things that they simply can't do
but in the middle of all this with these
priests falling suddenly they stop
right they stop what they're doing and
the question becomes why and they say
because the eye is coming the eye
is here right the leader of the black
priest is coming and where the
multiversal avengers are like one of the
worlds going
on and they they basically go to attack
him suddenly they're all frozen in place
right they can't move
and so it's like well who in the world
is this the head of the black priest
takes off his helmet and it's doctor
strange steven strange is now the one
who's leading
the black priest but doctor strange
brings them brings brings the
multiversal avengers to his location
right he brings them to his citadel and
kind of explains what's going on with
the nature of the black police remember
doctor strange was not always part of
the black priest but in the
eight month time jump he had actually
left earth and traveled out into the
multiverse and encountered the black
priest and what he basically learned
is is one what i already told you guys
about how they use their words in order
to create spells but
two the black priests are enigmatic and
the reason why they're enigmatic is
because they are the multiverse's own
defense system
it's like antibodies for the multiverse
they don't belong to anybody they
weren't created by anybody except for
the universe the multiverse itself that
when the multiverse started dying where
we do have things like the ivory kings
and you've got all these kind of all
this kind of stuff going on the
multiverse sought to defend itself and
in order to defend itself from its own
destruction
it created the black priests and what
the black priests were doing was going
from world to world and destroying those
worlds as many as they could
or at least enough that would stabilize
the collapse of the multiverse
that's really what they are that that's
the entire basis behind it unlike the
illuminati
in the beginning and the cabal now where
they're basically traveling from world
to world and wiping them out
simply in an effort to save their own
what the black priests are trying to do
is stabilize the collapse of the
multiverse they don't want to kill every
world they don't want to destroy every
world out there they just want to
stop the collapse right they want to
stop this kind of cascading effect of
everything basically dying and so what
you end up getting here
is is the question you know where the
black priest start asking things like
have you have you seen them like have
you seen
the ivory kings like have you
encountered them what can you tell us
about the ivory kings have you found out
a way to defeat them right remember we
still don't know who the ivory kings are
we haven't met them yet right like
they're just
beings who are out there that are wildly
powerful and that's kind of what's going
on doctor strange explains that there's
basically a war out there you've got
what's going on on earth going on on
earth right it always does right the
illuminati captain america blah blah
blah blah but on a bigger scale
you've got rabouma law the great
destroyer the person who seemingly
started the incursions and then you've
got the ivory kings who are part of the
incursions we don't really know what
their role is
but those two groups are going to war
right the forces of verbuma law the
forces of the ivory kings are at war
with one another the multiverse is
collateral damage right the destruction
of the multiverse hinges on this
and and what you had is the black priest
who emerged as the multiverse trying to
defend itself from being destroyed
as a means to try to balance out this
collapse right so a lot of like huge
parts going on
way out there in the multiverse itself
which really seems to dwarf what's going
on you know based on
earth but you end up having this idea
where where the group kind of comes
together and really it's star brand who
kicks out the idea and says okay then
here's what we'll do right we'll send
one group out there to basically find
robumo
like we'll we'll you know one group will
go out there find robumall and they will
kill him they will end the incur they'll
end his reign
and basically you know try to find some
way to stop the incursions through his
death and then we'll send
another group out there to face off
against the ivory kings and they will
kill the ivory kings and basically
destroy
both of these warring parties when
they're out of the way we can focus the
totality of our efforts
on finding a way to stop the incursions
and so that's when it's kind of thrown
out there
okay now's our chance now like like
literally flip a coin
right like whoever picks heads goes
after a boom along whoever picks tails
goes after the ivory kings right from
there we switch back to to reed richards
and
all these guys and we actually have reid
richards kind of sending off a message
to valeria right it's one of the things
that reed always does
is basically communicate with his kids
kind of teach them lessons when he can
where he can and one of the things that
hickman hits on here is that reid has
always kind of seemed dispassionate and
disconnected when the reality is
anything but and he basically kind of
goes and gives her this lesson
on how to win battles on how to win
conflicts and so he calls this one
making plans and the proper execution
thereof and he basically says that he
sees so many potential future outcomes
right the
the the potential outcomes out there are
are just
infinite and there are some that are
optimistic and there are some
that are less so and so one of the
things he tells her is you have to be
your absolute best
and we kind of end up switching over to
basically the archangel helicarrier
right the one the one ran by captain
america and what reid had done here was
initiate the first step of the plan that
remember captain america and his forces
track the illuminati using their
translocation which is to say whatever
the illuminati teleport from one
location to the next
the captain america tracks the signal
and then tries to locate them and while
he's usually ends up being late
at the very least it does give him the
belief that he's basically closing in on
them faster and faster right the more
they use this technology the more depth
shield becomes attracting it the faster
they can get to its location
and so what we end up having is reed
richards teleporting a chess piece just
like
three inches just enough to set off a
signal enough for shield to pick it up
and so right off the bat you immediately
know it's a trap and that's exactly
what's what's said by sam wilson right
you know where where maria hill and sam
wilson are there as kind of advisors for
for steve rogers the the response of
of sam wilson is okay look the issue
here is that they were just in rome
right it wouldn't make any sense that
they were more or less in the same
vicinity to suddenly teleport to another
location
in the same place right they're still in
rome and so sam wilson's kind of like it
doesn't make any sense right it doesn't
add up they know that we can track them
so they wouldn't be dumb enough
to teleport and then teleport again
right like because they know that we
would find them
like what this means is like if they've
done this it's because they intend for
us to find them and steve rogers is like
i know it's a trap
right but at this point he doesn't care
right it doesn't really matter to him
switch over to james rhodes and what
james rhodes is doing is basically
piloting a whole
you know a veritable army of war machine
robots basically he's piling them all
from a single device now it has had
somewhat of a mental toll but at the end
of the day he still seems to be able to
pull it off
but the translocation signal comes from
this one particular area and so you have
all these war machines who show up there
and they're looking for this signal and
they're like we're right on top of it
only for them to realize they are on top
of it they're on top of the hulk who
immediately comes smashing out of the
ground right and just starts tearing
these guys up and that's when reid comes
in with this next lesson right he says
for example
it's been said many times that if you
wait for all the information necessary
to make a correct decision the
opportunity to make any decision at all
might have passed you by and then he
says of course the opposite of that idea
is the uncomplicated maxim go with your
gut the argument there being
instinct is an evolutionary good bet
which is true
until you run into something or someone
a little higher up on the food chain or
in some instances
maybe just a bit more hungry most people
even gifted ones like yourself
talking to valeria tend to favor one of
these two principles
but the best course of action is an
amalgamation
maintaining a constant awareness of both
concepts and waiting to act
until the moment they intersect waiting
until both instinct and
intellect collide to put it bluntly what
you're looking
for is a plan that can be executed with
precision
but also implemented a temporally
minimized variables
maximize flexibility this is an awesome
lesson to learn
it's basically saying you want to be
able you want to be in a position to
where you have a plan
but you also want to make sure that plan
can adjust on the fly you do not want to
be rigid because if you're rigid as soon
as that plan
ends everything goes to pot now here's
the other cool thing that comes out of
this right you basically end up having
captain america launching a couple
different strikes
you've got the war machine suits that
are out there the illuminati are now
there so you've got black panther you've
got beast you've got reed richards
you've got captain britain
the incredible hulk of course is there
and the incredible hulk is just laying
waste right to all these different uh
these these different war machine robots
enter carol danvers one of the more
interesting things here is is the power
of carol danvers right i remember going
to see in the captain marvel movie and i
i i saw that interview where foggy was
like carol danvers is the most powerful
person in the marvel cinematic universe
as as her binary form yes right when
she's channeling the power of a star
absolutely she's the most powerful
person in the in the marvel cinematic
universe
carol danvers when it's just carol
danvers not a chance and that's exactly
what happens here
right like literally the incredible hulk
like she she tackles the incredible hulk
just starts pummeling him
and then when she's done she starts
catching her breath he's like do you
feel better and then just pummels her
into the sky right let me tell you
something carol danvers is cool but
regular carol danvers
not a chance no way she's she stands a
chance against against like the
incredible hulk
no that's that's not gonna happen no one
believes that
nobody should believe that but with
carol danvers being sent flying again
the incredible hulk is back onto the
battlefield not having to focus on her
and we're right back into it again and
then reed richards continues on he says
another thing you need to consider
is consistency of disposition can you
remain calm
while executing your plan the answer to
this must
always be yes psychological warfare
is the tool most often used by anyone
standing in opposition
to you achieving your goals manipulation
ultimatums
the threat of physical or emotional harm
these are tools of resistance
and while they may not be sufficient to
stop you like barnacles on a ship they
are enough
to cause drag and put your goals in
peril you
must at all times maintain composure now
i want to warn you valeria
there are those who will not understand
this disposition they will call you cold
and
unfeeling which is untrue we feel as
much as
anyone we hurt we cry but keep it in
check
until later like that's that's an
incredibly important lesson
that valeria needs to learn right that
the world will see her as somebody
disconnected
and unfeeling and uncaring the reality
of that is the exact
opposite that in order for that plan to
succeed she cannot be emotional right
you cannot be an emotional person you
have to be able to stick to your guns
you've got to be able to stay
strong to keep your conviction in the
face of overwhelming
uncertainty only in doing that can you
actually see your plans to fruition and
so with that being the case
you end up having captain america who's
consistently you know who's basically
making his way
over the site right the whole idea of
the war machines and all that kind of
stuff that was uh that was a preliminary
attack right that was an initial strike
it was there to try to try to maintain
or at least create a kind of battle zone
and then once captain america and his
forces get there
then to deploy the actual package and so
once captain america and his forces get
to the location reed richards chimes in
again and he says and finally
we come to strategy how to achieve your
goals i won't bother going into limited
scenarios clearly to find
opponents or situations these are simple
and you are well beyond needing your
father's advice on handling those a ship
pops out of nowhere it says
attention agents of shield and then we
go back to read but when facing a
well-seasoned or truly gifted opponent
you must always attempt to redefine your
opponent's base understanding of the
encounter
you attack their primary hypothesis for
example
if there is an expectation that a
conflict is between
two parties one of them being yours the
first thing you do
is you introduce a third and that's when
we end up finding out that robert de
costa
is part of this that robert decosta is
part of the plan of reed richards that
this has all been a plan of read the
entire time
robert de costa's new avengers all that
stuff has all been a part of reid's plan
and so what we end up doing
is switching over to doctor doom right i
know a lot of you guys were really
curious about
this doctor doom the molecule man a lot
of you guys really wanted to know what
was going on
and it's kind of a funny thing here
because doom has been putting the pieces
together right while
everything else has been going on while
everything else has been happening
robert de costa forming his own team
that goes out into the multiverse and so
on so forth you've got captain america
chasing down the illuminati you've got
the illuminati trying to stop the cabal
and all of them are trying to find some
way to end the incursions
dr doom has been working inside his
citadel to figure out to answer
questions right to get questions sorted
out and it's one of these things where
he starts talking to the molecule man
who is kind of progressively going
crazier
and and what what dr doom really hits at
here
is there is something big going on and
that the molecule man owen reese has
everything to do with it
right like everything that's happening
with the incursions seemed to basically
tie
into owen reese and the reason why is
because the energy emanating off this
fragment this rock the one that fell
when the incursion happened on earth in
latvia when we first encountered the map
makers
doctor doom's been analyzing it and the
energy signature of this rock
matches the energy signature of owen
reese so something is going on here
and it's one of these things where owen
reese is like this you know this is kind
of strange you know like
and initially he almost kind of kind of
you know throws out the idea that doctor
doom's a liar and dr doom is like i'm
not a liar right i never lie
and owen's response is yeah but if what
you believe is the truth and if what you
were told you know if somebody told you
something and they said this is the
truth and you believe it because they
told you but what they told you was a
lie
are you not a liar maybe you're a liar
unintentionally but a liar nonetheless
because what you're saying is not true
regardless of the reasons for why you
believe it and this is basically owen
reese telling dr doom
nothing that you believe is going on
here is actually right
like nothing you believe is going on
here is correct nothing
like nothing's transpiring like there's
what you believe is happening there's
what the avengers believe is happening
here's what
what captain america thinks is happening
there's what everybody out there thinks
is happening
but none of them really know the truth
and so he says let me show you
let's go on a trip snaps his fingers and
the two of them disappear now
undoubtedly you guys are probably asking
where in the heck did they go
they teleported to the very beginning of
the incursions
they're teleporting to the place where
the whole thing gets explained we find
out how the incursion started we find
out everything going on with like rabumi
law and we find out what's going on with
with the ivory kings and all that kind
of stuff which we'll cover
later because we are bringing this video
to an end if you are new here to comics
explain cliffhangers if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you